the overweening arrogance Barack Obama
cursed his party for the last eight
years and led to the rise of Donald
Trump after spending nearly a decade
acting as a political celebrity Obama
has now been replaced by an actual
political celebrity after spending a
decade to crying Americans his racists
and bigots Obama has been replaced by a
man who tells americans they don't need
to be ashamed of disagreeing with Obama
Obama more than any other single
personality except for Hillary Clinton
felt the wrath of the voters on november
nine but there is good news according to
Obama the election was not about him he
explained out a conference call with
other Democrats yesterday quote let me
tell you something we got more done than
any Administration in the last one knows
how many decades look one of the
challenges that I've discovered being
president is I'd like to be organizer
entry but it's hard you got cereal you
got NATO you have summit meetings
economic issues you have to deal with on
an ongoing basis you try to get
legislation ball this morning Obama
added there is a mismatch between
frustration and anger because people
seem to think I did a pretty good job
this has been a running theme with Obama
the only reason americans don't bow to
his superior wisdom is we have been
dramatically misinformed if only the
great sage of our age had the time to
speak to americans personally you know
between the rounds of golf and the
Kimmel appearances he would've bought
Hillary would have won but it doesn't
matter after all he's really really
popular so clearly this had nothing to
do with him now if that sounds like a
switch that's because it is Obama spent
most of his campaign explaining his
legacy was inextricably intertwined with
Hillary Clinton's election in a video he
cut just weeks before the election he
said quote if you want to give Michelle
and Meghan good send-off get people
registered to vote if you care about our
legacy realize everything we stand for
is it stable Obama even called it a
personal insult to his legacy if black
voters didn't show up to vote for
Hillary but that's the wonderful thing
about being a narcissist like President
Obama if something wonderful happens
it's solely due to you just remember
Obama's self-glorifying announcement
about the killing of bin Laden when it
sounded like Obama repelled down from a
helicopter and put two in bin Laden's
face if something terrible happens
however it's not Obama's fault it's
everybody else's fault it's this sort of
narcissism that lies the root of
Democrats defeat in 2016 and future
defeats if they continue to do this
routine they think they're lost have
nothing to do with them it's just
because of Republican malfeasance and
cruelty and so they don't bother to
change their behavior well thank God for
that the more they insist their
impeccable
the more they double down on losing
strategy so for the last time thanks
Obama I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
alrighty so we begin today with so much
to talk about today we'll get to the
update from DePaul University the reason
that I'm broadcasting from this hotel
room as you can see this beautiful
luxurious hotel room and not our normal
studios would be with the Western barn
wall Becker is because i am a
broadcaster from Chicago where Rama man
will be bursting down the door at any
moment to drag me away and call me an
illegal immigrant but before we get to
all of the content we have for you in
there plenty first have to give a shout
out to our new advertisers over at C so
C so is sdes Oh calm and this is a
streaming comedy network so it's all
comedy all the time commercial free it's
like three ninety-nine a month and
they've got all the old episodes of
Parks and Rec and all the old episodes
of the office with Ricky Gervais that
got the entire Monty Python catalogue
it's been jable comedy for people who
really like comedy at sea so calm SE es
el Jack on a bunch of original series as
well and to go to see so calm right now
and use the promo code been you get two
months for free so if you're looking at
the world and thinking boy I could use a
little comedy see so calm is in place
for you my wife and I love it we use it
all the time see so calm again use
that's that promo code bend and you get
two free months and you can watch
comedies of you're treating without
commercials okay so lots to get to today
so first the update from from DePaul so
I'm supposed to speak at depaul
university tonight now as you may recall
DePaul University bands me about what
would have been about a year not even
here gonna be six months ago was my
Olivia napolis spoke here and the
students went nuts and rushed the stage
and so they decided that instead of
punishing the students for being
terrible people and for violating basic
standards Western civilization they
decided instead to to ban Milo and then
they also banned me for good measure
just because there had been a basic riot
over at Cal State LA so here's the
situation right now they banned me the
yellow America's foundation chapter here
invited me they also invited Christina
Hoff Sommers is wonderful theorist about
feminism to speak tonight when they
found out that I was coming they
immediately threatened to cancel the
entire event if i were to speak to which
i said okay fine i'll just common l sit
in the audience and if i have a question
that lasts half an hour then that'll be
okay but they said no we can't even
allow you to sit in the audience now so
now that they are
really threatening that if I step on
campus this is the latest they are
threatening that if I set foot on campus
they will arrest me is is my
understanding of the situation although
i would like clarification from the
local police department that will be
forced to take me to lock up if i set
foot on campus don't worry we have
contingency plans will go forward as
plans things will happen tonight it'll
be a lot of fun we'll be streaming all
that but it does demonstrate the
insanity and weakness to the left
meanwhile it is amazing that the same
left that will activate the cops to shut
down free speech in a room that is a
lecture they have nothing to say about
these massive protests that are taking
place across the country people being
beaten up things being shut down
freeways being shut down streets being
shut down the left is truly an
astonishing display of hypocrisy and and
fascism and we will bring you that lot
mean I'm Ashley I will go to campus and
we will bring that to you live stream it
will have a bunch of people taping it
there's supposed to be some massive
protests as I say my understanding is
they're not going to allow me on campus
and we'll see whether that is true or
not meanwhile the left continues to
demonstrate just why they lost and why
they deserve to lose morally left always
deserves to leave morally but the real
reason I think that they lost in this
election cycle is people just got pissed
off of the life people just said you
know what we are so sick of this crap
you and your whiny baby attitudes you
and your calling everybody racist sexist
bigot homophobe it's very tiresome and
we're just done we're not going to do
that anymore that's not stopping the
left from from doing more of what the
left likes to do for example here is a
woman who was on Facebook live streaming
herself for aiding an iowa police
officer for committing the grave sin
this iowa police officer committed the
grave sin while wearing a black band
around his arm in honor of a fallen
officer you're live we're building an
audience
okay we're streaming live in Hawaii
downtown cedar rapids we got the cocoa
wearing black name under band again
sorry about when cops got whacked in the
morning but she doesn't give us knew
about the man who's in critical care at
the University of Iowa Hospitals and
Clinics with a bullet in his net
wonderful vicious thug brothers in blue
I don't know what to say y'all I think
this of witc H is going to seriously
arrest me because some uptight Iowan a
whole thought I was impolite tell that
police girl she has a cute ass and she
can spend the night in my solitary
bathroom my friend Dennis just look that
up where am I broo he Mia stop this
idiot so she live streams this whole
thing up here on the black band is
around the badge you can see in the
video not not around the arm in any case
this is what the left is the West takes
glory in this this is sort of
reminiscent of that woman who live
streamed her her her conversation with
an uber driver where she lectured uber
driver about cultural appropriation cuz
ya know hula dancer on his phone his
dashboard the more the left exposes
itself is the beautiful thing about
social media is why we're gonna have
lots of cameras there tonight the
beautiful thing about all of this is
that the more left exposes itself the
more they demonstrate just why Americans
should not trust them with anything
under any circumstances and I may not
like the form that the backlash took and
the Potomac Donald Trump but the
backlash itself is wildly justified and
the left deserves everything they get
from all of this meanwhile the left
continues to double down most Americans
are not in favor of illegal immigration
most Americans are not cool with illegal
immigration we may say that you know
people who have illegal immigrated a
long time ago and have proved that they
just want to be here to work with those
people maybe we should provide them a
pathway to legalization but the vast
majority of people believe that criminal
illegal aliens particularly should
immediately be important and people who
are living off the public dollar should
also be deported because they didn't
follow the rules because we do have
rules and because any country has the
right to uphold its borders and
determined
who's coming in and who is going out and
when one of those people deserve to be
here or not that's not stopping the left
from doubling down on their full embrace
of illegal immigration Rahm Emanuel who
is the mayor of Chicago again a city
where I am presumably banned from
speaking on campus enforced by local law
enforcement under the control I guess of
Chicago PD or with in association with
Chicago PD that's bad but rom manual
says you'll definitely make sure that we
never arrest anybody who's an illegal
immigrant here's Rahm Emanuel former
chief of staff to President Obama and
now mayor of Chicago important for
families that are anxious it is
important for children and adolescents
that are unsure because of Tuesday to
understand that the city of Chicago is
your home you are always welcome in this
city always to be clear about what
Chicago is it always will be a sanctuary
city to all those who are after
Tuesday's election very nervous there's
filled with anxiety has been spoken to
you are safe in chicago okay so you're
safe in chicago the local law
enforcement will not cooperate with the
feds and he's not the only one saying is
the LAPD Chief Charlie Beck he said that
they're not going to cooperate with the
feds either with regard to deportation
and immigration councilman from Boston
said the same thing here's this
councilman from Boston saying the same
routine Trump's hardline is causing some
sanctuary cities to push back and
reaffirm their status Boston is a
sanctuary city city councilor Tito
Jackson is worried that undocumented
residents will be afraid to go to the
police for help or even send their kids
to school of the police department if
you call them and you need help they
will help you and they're not going to
turn you in to the feds mayor Walsh is
also staying the course saying in a
statement we are a welcoming city for
all these are Boston values and no
policy will change them okay so they're
saying that they're not gonna change
policy there either this is not a big
surprise mean Democrats are wedded to be
illegal immigration they hope to
eventually give a lot of legal
immigrants the right to vote and then
they can change the demographic
the voting population in the country
that's the goal here by the way when
people say pathway to legalization that
does not mean pathway to voting you can
give somebody an eagle status my wife
had legal status in the United States
for many many years she had green card
but she wasn't actually given
citizenship until I think it's five
years ago six years ago so yeah that you
can have there are lots millions people
living in the United States legally we
don't have the right to vote so it is
worthwhile making that distinction but
what what all these folks are saying is
we're not going to help out the feds now
I think that it is worthwhile noting
that the left now is in love with
federalism the left now loves federalism
and so it used to be I'm old enough to
remember when the state of Arizona under
Jan Brewer Governor Jan Brewer they were
in favor of what they called Senate bill
1070 and Senate bill 1070 said to the
feds okay look when we arrest people
we're going to take down their illegal
immigration data and then we're going to
hand them over to federal law
enforcement and Barack Obama sued the
state of Arizona saying stop enforcing
federal law it's our job not to enforce
federal law it's a federalism was bad
from Barack Obama's perspective
federalism is constantly bad from
President Obama's perspective he said
this about gay marriage she sent us
about abortion we have these hot spots
we look terrible it's hodgepodge ball
well when it comes to Republicans now
dominating the federal government then
all of a sudden federalism is back in
style and this of course is why
federalism is a wonderful thing letcha
cago try and do what Chicago's trying to
do and yes the local law enforcement has
no obligation to enforce federal
immigration law they don't mean the
federal government has the obligation to
enforce federal law the federal
government can attach strings to the to
the city for not enforcing federal law
that they can they contend the city
we're going to cut off your subsidies if
you don't enforce federal law but
federalism is a wonderful thing I just
find it hilarious that the left is
suddenly in love with federalism again
after spending an enormous amount of
time saying that federalism is the end
of the world and the worst thing that
ever happened to anybody that I do find
amusing and kind of incredible so they
will continue to push forward though
with this radical left agenda I don't
know if they assume that they're just
going to come back next time and sweep
to victory because people were asleep
during this election cycle on their side
or what do they think that the
demographics are moving in their favor
but they're clearly doubling down on
everything that they already think about
how elections work they're clearly
already doubling down on everything they
already think about politics which is a
pretty amazing thing we will take a
quick break and say hello to our friends
over Birch gold by the way well if
you're worried about what the economy is
going to do if you're concerned Janet
Yellen is going to raise interest rates
if you're concerned that the stock
market in real estate market are
overvalued and that chaos is ahead you
may want to take some your money and put
it into precious metals my friends at
Birch gold calm Birch gold calm / Ben
these are these are the people who will
help you invest in precious metals that
can help you reinvest your IRA or 401k
into precious metals and protect
yourself from the vicissitudes of the
market they do have an A+ rating from
the better business bureau I think you
should ask all your questions of them
they have a 16-page freakin about
investing in precious metals you should
give them a call or you should check out
their website at Birch gold calm / Ben
if you're interested in putting part of
your assets in precious metals okay
President Obama to he too is doubling
down the doubling down never stops the
President Obama again the nice thing
about Obama being a textbook narcissist
one of the wonderful things about him
being a textbook narcissist is he has
never done anything wrong ever so he was
asked yesterday by NBC's Chris Jansing
about whether he kills any
responsibility at all for the election
of Donald Trump and clearly you should
write clearly he should I mean the fact
is that Donald Trump was a direct
response to Barack Obama in a thousand
ways everything from political celebrity
to political celebrity everything from
race-baiting to anti race-baiting on
part of white folks the idea that Obama
was saying that all the white folks in
America were implicitly biased or
Hillary said that and then Trump said
you you don't have to feel like a racist
just because you oppose Obama the fact
that Obama ignored the concerns of so
many members of the population by
running roughshod over them and hanging
with celebrities and here comes drunk
who clearly doesn't give a crap about
other celebrities very much in a
thousand ways all of this is a response
to Obama ISM Obama's asked if he bears
responsibility and as you can imagine
his answer no not the slightest and you
answered talk to me if he wins about how
responsible I feel about it I wonder do
you feel any responsibility for the
election of Donald Trump well first of
all I think it's fair to say that I was
surprised by the election results and
I've said so
I still don't feel responsible for what
the president-elect says or does but I
do feel a responsibility as president
united states to make sure that i
facilitate a good transition and i
present to him as well as the American
people my best thinking my best ideas
about how you move the country forward
to speak out with respect to areas where
I think the Republican Party is wrong
but to pledge to work with them on those
things that I think will advance the
causes of security and prosperity and
just avoids the question do you feel any
responsibility for Trump 8-11 well I
feel a responsibility to keep doing
exactly what I'm doing I mean that that
was not the question of course he
doesn't feel responsibility he's a
pathological narcissist he's never done
anything wrong that's why every time
he's asked a question about why the
American people don't like one or
another of his policies was immediate
response to all of that very clearly is
I don't care what the American people
have to say if only I had spoken more
clearly to them if only they were wise
enough to understand little me
everything would have been fine Obama
did try to give his explanation of what
happened in this election he said people
are obviously disaffected but he doesn't
explain why they're disaffected in this
situation we're turning over a country
that has challenges has problems and
obviously there are people out there who
were feeling deeply disaffected
otherwise we wouldn't have had the
results that we had in the election on
the other hand if you look at the basic
indicators of where the country is right
now the unemployment rate is as low as
it's been in 89 years incomes and wages
have both gone up over the last year
faster than they have
in a decade or two we got historically
low uninsured rates the financial
systems are stabled the stock market is
hovering around its all-time high and
401ks have been restored the housing
market has recovered we have challenges
internationally but our most immediate
challenge with respect to ISIL we're
seeing significant progress you know we
can stop him there I mean again they
asked him that remember the question
here was what exactly do you think
happened here and his answer was people
are disaffected and then he gives an
entire list of what a wonderful job he
does so the answer really is according
to president obama because the people
are morons the people are stupid right
if they only understood how grand and
glorious obama has been if only he had
let's say a compliant media to repeat
24-7 how wonderful obama is or if only
he had a bunch of Hollywood celebrities
to talk about constantly what a
wonderful man he is or if only he had
the UN to talk about how wonderful is
Ramon Lee won a Nobel Prize oh wait he
had all of those things and he's still
lost yeah maybe because people are
disaffected for a reason it's this sort
of blindness that leads to a
catastrophic electoral losses again
Obama's narcissism led them down the
primrose path here Obama insisted that
the Obama coalition which which kept
alienating lower class lower lower
income white voters the the the same
coalition that alienated a bunch of
people in the middle of the country
we're sick of watching obama hobnob with
jimmy fallon he keeps saying those
people are just dumb that's all it comes
down to those people are just stupid and
that sort of scoring for the voter is
not going to is not going to work in any
real way now he did say one thing that I
thought was was true now i have to give
obama credit when it comes to the
transition to trump he's actually done a
good job he's actually staying out of
the way for the most part he's not
throwing too many bombs I would like to
see Donald I would like to see President
Obama condemned the rioting and
protesting that's occurring because
Trump was elected but aside from that
you have to acknowledge that he's doing
a good job with the transition he's told
a lot of Lies however about why this
happened in the first place but I think
he did tell one true then it's kind of
an important for
and speaks to where the Republican Party
goes from here his President Obama
talking about what he thinks of Trump
ideologically what he thinks wouldn't
philosophically says the Trump isn't
really a conservative he's a pragmatist
I don't think he is ideological I think
ultimately is he's pragmatic in that way
and that can serve him well as long as
he's got good people around him and he
has a clear sense of direction okay so
he says that he's a pragmatist he's not
an ideologue I think that that is
basically right i think that the Donald
Trump considers himself a pragmatist
just the guy who's going to get stuff
done now in American politics there's a
really unfortunate tendency to buy into
this kind of ball and it is bull when
people say that they are just
pragmatists that they just look at the
facts in front of them and they make a
decision about the best policy that is
never true that is never true because
how you see the facts is shaped by your
worldview if you see man is inherently
good that's going to change how you see
the facts if you see man is capable of
both good and evil that changes the fact
if you see freedom as inherently
dangerous that changes how you look at
the facts if you see freedom is the
highest purpose of mankind then that
changes how you see the facts ideology
philosophy matters what we talk about
every day here on the program I don't
think that that Trump really has a core
philosophy or a core belief system and
that tends toward bigger government it
tends toward more executive power it
tends toward the idea that all policy
can be decided just by the Great God
kings of wisdom we sit on high and rule
us and I think that there is some truth
to that about Trump if you look at the
people historically in America who have
called themselves pragmatists Woodrow
Wilson was probably the first president
to call himself openly a pragmatist he
said I'm a pragmatist I'm an expert my
job is to get the experts in a position
to make great decisions to help you the
people and of course he ended up
exponentially growing government because
either the experts are capable of
running your life or you're capable of
running your life but not both and he
thinks that you know what ur Wilson
thought the experts were capable Barack
Obama coming into office he kept
describing himself as a pragmatist but
it turns out that in order to be a
governmental pragmatist you actually
have to believe deep down the government
has the power to change things for the
better enormously if you believe that
that's what makes you a pragmatist with
the government
because if you're a pragmatist of
conservative bet you say okay I think
the government kind of sucks at
everything like for example I think that
its pragmatic to talk about drug
legalization because the government
sucks at the war on drugs they're really
quite terrible at it okay that's it
that's a pragmatist philosophy but it's
not pragmatism driving that it's a basic
idea that the government is bad at
things you can be pragmatist on the
other side and say well the government
obviously isn't doing enough on the drug
war so we need to pour money into it
every set of facts is going to be viewed
differently based on what your worldview
is your worldview is going to help
dictate how you see any particular set
of facts and the fact that people who
call themselves ests are rarely
conservatives people who say that as a
practical thing i'm going to leave the
government that i'm going to do what's
good for america that never ends well
and i do think that the president obama
is largely correct about Donald Trump on
this he's gonna be an ad hoc policy guy
I'm hoping he's surrounding himself with
some of the right people we'll go
through some good Trump bad Trump in a
minute talk about some of
disappointments some of them are quite
good some of them are a little more
questionable and we'll get to all of
that in just a minute but to do that you
have to go over to daily wire.com
because we have to end over at Facebook
and YouTube go today lee weyer calm and
subscribe you can check us out over
there and in eight dollars a month well
we'll buy you access to the rest of this
podcast live plus you get to be part of
the mailbag you get my book if you get
an annual subscription you get my book
for free for leech and sign which is
pretty cool plus we have a bunch of
other goodies that are coming up in the
next in the next few months you also
right now if you subscribe then you can
actually get rid of the ads on the page
which is pretty date so make sure you
check that out daily wire coms become
part of the most we must listen to
conservative podcast in America
you